Damian:
This is one of the craziest
people
Damian:
who pulled off one of the
biggest scams in American history.
Amy:
We are looking for Eric Conn
for defrauding the U.S.
taxpayers of more than 550
million dollars.
♪♪
Ned:
Eric Conn was one of the biggest
lawyers here, in Appalachia.
Jeff:
The town loved him and the
people loved him.
He was a phenomenon.
Eric Conn was Mr. Social
Security.
♪♪
Ned:
He was on the radio, he was on
television.
TV spokesman:
This has been an advertisement
for Eric C. Conn.
We laughed at him, you know.
Melinda:
But everybody wanted to meet
him.
You couldn’t miss him,
especially when he went on the
run.
♪♪
Damian:
The way he did it was
incredible.
Damian:
And there was porn stars, and
voodoo dolls,
Damian:
and Rolls Royces, and flashy
suits, and brothels.
He opened a Halloween-themed
brothel.
Nobody knows how many people
he’s been married to.
Everything about this guy is too
much to believe, but it all
happened.
♪♪
At the time I thought he’s
helping me.
Dennis:
I hit rock bottom. I lost
everything I had.
Ned:
My clients are victims of his
criminal conduct.
Damian:
This is one of the poorest parts
in the United States
Damian:
and he’s getting filthy rich off
the whole thing.
A ‘baller’ in the eastern
Kentucky.
♪♪
Damian:
There was three investigations
happening at once.
My tires had been slashed with a
knife.
Damian:
These were bad, bad people.
I lived in fear of going to
work.
♪♪
The politics stink to high
heaven.
The only thing government hates
more than a rapist or a child
molester is a tax-evader.
We were like, ‘Freeze!'
♪♪
Damian:
He walked across the border with
a dog named Curly.
Amy:
Through Mexico, into Guatemala.
We were that close and now he’s
gone.
Damian:
Eric was planning his biggest
caper yet.
♪♪